[Music]
from the director of Suicide Squad the
writer of Victor Frankenstein and
trigger warning entertainment comes an
allegory about race relations from the
director of Suicide Squad the writer of
Victor Frankenstein and trigger warning
entertainment fairy lives don't matter
today this is gonna be a bumpy ride huh
right
login to Netflix your first choice for
prestige television and last choice for
movies to see a film that would have
crushed at the box office if buying a
ticket for the same is something
auto-playing after you pass out during
mine hunter don't lie netflix i woke up
to an Adam Sandler movie once those
views don't count see Will Smith like
you've never seen him before
not as the wild card caught with a
by-the-book partner from bad boys or the
wild card cop with a by-the-book partner
from men in black or the wild card cop
with a by-the-book partner from my robot
or a wild card soldier with a
by-the-book partner and Independence Day
or a wild card ex soldier with a
by-the-book partner in Wild West or a
wild card mercenary with a pile of a
partner in Suicide Squad but a wild card
cop with a by-the-book partner who's an
Borg whoa explore a movie that's more
than a cop drama it's a complicated
social metaphor that explores what it
means to be human
we're gonna Teddy bar gunfight dive
sorry
sorry couldn't keep it in there blending
tired fantasy tropes with tired buddy
cop tropes to explore a world of racial
allegories where orcs are stand-ins for
the historical mistreatment of black
people and that's pretty much it works
are black people and one of them is a
cop
agent know if you're a cop first fallen
or first if the movie has anything else
to say
I guess it's that Mexicans are scary
yeah this ain't get out you've never
seen a premise this interesting gets so
squandered where all of the creative
possibilities of a fantasy world being
part of our own for 2,000 years
everything turned out exactly the same
no seriously
our history is the same Mexicans
thuggish businesses are the same we're
in a stolen Toyota Corolla even our pop
culture didn't change take your fat
Shrek looking ass back to Fiona
how'd the Shrek still exist is it a
documentary there's dragons flying
around but our buildings never changed
our top doing they never even mentioned
that you can't just add the word magic
and claim it's any different from a
normal cop movie that's your task force
all right the magic feds aah so gear up
for the film that got burned by critics
for either being too woke or not woken
up but wasted the core premise of a
modern-day fantasy world none of which
will matter to Netflix because with an
infinite amount of money you can
greenlight an infinite amount of stupid
ideas to keep an infinite number of
people from ever going to a theater
again well we had a good run movies now
to never leave the house
starring Will Smith the door for Cobb
the filth element and Orlando do and
also starring the falling bright sequels
we write for significantly less than
three million dollars to reporters track
down a story but one of them is a Balrog
which means she's Filipino a
mild-mannered vampire inherits a coffee
shop but there's a twist vampires are
Guatemalan and a frost giant but he's a
Jew note that one that could be my Star
Wars edge Lord of the Rings
oh she's alright she's okay come on
everyone clap if you believe no she's
dead hey screen junkies check out our
newest series feature destinations
featuring tour guides to your favorite
movie locations click the box in the
left and you can flow to in Derry Maine
curse you perry the platypus
peanut butter french fried tacos the
fish banging movie come on writers it's
grinding Nemo